une bonne centaine de lycéens était
présent ce matin devant le lycée duhamel
de dole des élèves qui faisaient
ralentir la circulation et qui bloqué
tout accès à leur établissement avec au
coeur des revendications
la réforme du baccalauréat annoncées
pour la rentrée prochaine
nous notre cause c'est la réforme du bac
on a peur de ça et qu'est ce qu'on va
devenir après avec parcours sucre
qu'est-ce que nous étudions on va
devenir après le bac on sait même pas
donc moi je trouve que c'est aussi un
ras-le-bol général que c'est que les
cheminots ont appelé aussi à la grève
les infirmières tout le monde donc je
pense que c'est un ras-le-bol général
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est avec notre
gilet jaune vous le voyez encadrés par
des adultes gilet jaune et par des
membres de la fcpe
les élèves étaient aussi soutenu par
quelques professeurs inquiet de
l'uniformisation du baccalauréat et de
la disparition des filières l'élève
s'ils n'arrivent pas à obtenir une
dérogation pour aller dans un ultra
glissement donc il devra se satisfaire
du choix qu'on lui propose
on voit le cas à l'heure actuelle donc
sur salins les bains alors été long à
une filière économique et sociale ce qui
est prévu pour la rentrée prochaine
c'est une disparition des sciences
économiques et sociales dans les
établissements qui ne proposerait pas
les spécialités souhaité par les élèves
une possibilité de cours dispensés à
distance est aussi envisagée